there we go hi everyone welcome back to
my channel man carrying nautical history
today we're going to be talking about
the pros and cons of the Virginia class
submarine I know fan favorite but what
if I told you this submarine is secretly
woke yeah so that's basically the end of
the skit you know the concept of the
jokes like that almost every YouTuber is
known for breaking the fourth wall the
fourth wall break is a concept deriving
from theater in which the performers on
stage do not interact directly with the
audience as if there is a fourth
invisible wall locking them inside the
fiction of the performance YouTubers how
ever almost constantly address Their
audience and comment on the artifice of
the medium even asking the audience to
directly participate like And subscribe
Etc when you think about it YouTube is a
uniquely fourth while breaking medium
and such a direct relationship between
performer and viewer has likely led to
furthering parasocial relationships and
unhealthy internet consumption in Modern
Life do you love me